I'm going to introduce the panel as a
whole and then we'll call them up first
we will have a presentation however by
representative Bernie Sanders who's been
introduced before he's going to take ten
minutes and in that impossible ten
minutes is going to tell us both
what full funding of these covenant
promises would be and how to pay for it
I would disagree with Reverend Jackson
only in the sense of his introduction
having said that representative Sanders
is not only seasoned but mellowed I
would agree with the former but
certainly not the latter and his
colleague from the Congress is shaking
her head as well we hope he doesn't
mellow we're counting on his leadership
in the Congress representative Bernie
Sanders
let me begin by thanking Jessie Jackson
who has disappeared I guess because
whenever it seems that the progressive
community has got to come together to
analyze what's happening and where we
should go it's Jesse Jackson who makes
the call so I think we owe him a debt of
gratitude and I'm also delighted that
Secretary Rice was here and I guess
later Secretary shillelagh is gonna be
here we have so many people well coming
together today to talk about how we can
create a country and how we can create a
government which represents all of the
people for a change rather than just the
rich and the very rich and it's about
time we did that I think when one
recalls the horrors of Reaganomics
fahara is not just the reality of what
they have created but rather it is their
refusal to deal with the very difficult
and burning issues facing our country
some of you may remember that in 1984
when the guts of this country were being
torn apart when homelessness was growing
when the health care system was
disintegrating when the standard of
living of American workers was declining
when more and more of our children were
becoming hungry when our infrastructure
was collapsing when leveraged buyouts
with throwing workers out on the street
that's when we saw those lovely
30-second ads about morning in America
remember that the lights were going out
all over the country the people were
suffering and the ads were telling us
morning in America things were getting
better things were getting worse and I'm
delighted that at least while I
personally will have differences with
President Clinton at least there is now
an acknowledgement of the severity of
the problems placing them on the table
and then let's be
to work together to solve them but we
can solve them unless we acknowledge
them and what we have got to acknowledge
is that Reaganomics was one of the great
frauds in the history of this country
and we got over turning my job this
afternoon is to very briefly suggest
some ideas some ideas as to how we can
raise the necessary funds to do as
President Clinton has said put people
first in other words if we all agree
that it is a national disgrace that 80
million Americans either have no health
insurance or are underinsured then we've
got to figure out how do we solve that
problem if we agree that our
infrastructure is falling apart and at
exactly the same time we have millions
of workers in the building trades area
ready to go to work to rebuild America
and yet they're unemployed then we got
to figure out a way to raise the funds
so that we can rebuild our
infrastructure put workers back to work
at decent wages if we agree that it is
unacceptable that two million Americans
sleep out on the street then we've got
to figure out how do we raise the money
to build the affordable housing to put
people into decent housing how do we
raise the money to feed five million
children who are hungry how do we raise
the money to deal with the environmental
crises all over this country which are
making our people sick how do we raise
the money to fulfill the president's
goal of making sure that every kid in
America who wants a college education
can afford to get one that's gonna cost
us money how do we do that and on and on
how do we raise the money to do those
things let me very briefly throw out
some suggestions as how we might do that
number one terms of health care I have
some very good news and the good news is
that you don't need any more money to
provide comprehensive while
the healthcare every man woman and child
this country does already spending much
more than we have to spend we don't need
more money but what do we need we need
political courage to take on the
insurance companies and the drug
companies and the doctors and to come
together and finally establish a
single-payer national healthcare system
guaranteeing healthcare to all people so
in other words on that issue there is
good news
it does take money to rebuild the
infrastructure but in the area of health
care please understand we are spending
40 percent more per capita than the
Canadians double what many European
countries are spending on health care
and so many of our people don't have any
insurance at all so what we need there
is not as some have suggested including
people in the Clinton administration we
don't need tens of billions of dollars
more you don't need to raise taxes on
workers health insurance benefits in
order to pay for national health care we
could do it now if we have the guts to
do it let's do it
but for many areas in fact we are going
to need money to rebuild America to feed
the kids to provide educational
opportunity let's talk for a brief
moment as to how in a fair and
progressive way we might raise that
money now others have already talked
about that
congresswoman Velazquez Secretary Rice
let me briefly go over some facts during
the 1980s as you all know while the
standard of living of American workers
declined the very richest people became
much richer according to a 1991 study
listen closely to this one tax cuts for
the richest 1 million American families
and that's people those incomes average
a mere 675 thousand bucks apiece
low-income families those people between
1978 and 1992 they as a result of the
tax cuts that they received added one
trillion dollars to the national debt
one trillion dollars in tax cuts the
same fuddy study found that the same 1
million families the richest people in
America pay 30% less of their incomes in
taxes than they would have had the 1977
tax code remained in existence so what
does that tell us
when we look for funding for feeding
hungry children for putting people into
affordable housing it means to me that
the time is now in a very strong way to
say the wealthiest people in this
country they're going to have to start
paying their fair share of taxes
and that means to my mind going much
higher than raising the income tax rate
from 31 to 36 percent it means among
other things we should go higher than
that it means that we must create a
progressive corporate tax rate it means
we must be prepared to do way with much
of the tax deductibility for business
meals and entertainment some of our
friends were able to write off going to
the country clubs are going to finally
start having to look at the hungry
children on the sidewalk as they go to
the country club and maybe maybe pay a
tax on that and it means doing away with
the tax breaks that now exists to help
companies acquire runaway plants that
move out of the country and also I think
that the time is right that we even may
have to contemplate going be beyond just
an income tax and talk about a tax on
wealth I think that that's appropriate
as well
secondly when we talk about how we're
going to raise the money that we need it
is absolutely imperative and impossible
not to look at the bloated military
budget I think very few people have
illusions that the world we're living in
now is wonderful is perfectly safe that
we should disarm America nobody thinks
that but on the other hand there is some
excellent news the fact of the matter is
that the Cold War is over a longtime
adversary the Soviet Union does not
exist Russia wants to join NATO Russia
has significantly cut down on their
military spending lack while lesser is
no longer in jail in Poland he's the
president of the country
East Germany is no longer threatening
West Germany it is part of West Germany
and so forth and so on in my view and
the view of people who know more about
this than I do this country today can
very safely reduce military spending by
50 percent over the next four years
and use those hundreds of billions of
dollars in freedom money to reinvest in
America and to deal with the deficit
let me also touch very briefly when we
talk about how we are going to acquire
some money it's always a funny thing you
know when we need money for hungry
children when we need money to create
productive jobs they always tell us
there's not money available but you know
what when they wanted a war in the
Persian Gulf no problem
plenty of money available and let me
tell you someplace else where there's
always money available in the next
couple of months unless I'm very
mistaken president Democrats Republicans
are going to come before the people and
say they need another 40 or 50 billion
dollars to bail out the Savings and Loan
industry
well the 40 or 50 billion dollars now I
happen to think that with all of this
talk about the deficit and how we may
have to ask senior citizens to take cuts
and colas and raise middle income taxes
and gas taxes and so forth and so
everybody is so concerned about the
deficit why the hell are we dumping
another forty billion dollars into the
deficit to bail out the savings and loan
industry makes sense to anybody here all
right so I think that there are fairer
and more progressive ways to deal with
the S&L bailout than to dump it into the
deficit let me simply conclude and pick
up a point I think that Nydia less was
made earlier and that is that we now
have the potential to make some very
fundamental changes in this country but
we cannot do it unless we come together
and stand up and fight 45% of the people
don't vote poor people don't vote many
working people don't vote our voices are
not being heard the good news is that
after twelve years reaganomics is gone
but don't anybody think that there is
not an enormous struggle in front of us
so my hope is that those of us in
Congress those of in the unions of the
Women's Committee all of you that we all
begin to stand together and say that
this country has the potential the
the best country that they ever was and
we can do that if we stand together and
let's do that
thank you very much